well we made a pretty obvious suggestion
on the show last night why don't we have
civilian review boards
for our schools it's not like schools
aren't important they're maybe the most
important thing we pay for in a lot of
places they're the main thing we pay for
they're the biggest budget item in most
towns the schools
we're educating our children to become
adults and run the country
that they're inheriting so why don't we
know what's happening in the classrooms
why don't we have cameras
in every classroom again it's obvious we
have cameras monitoring congress
city council meetings our police
officers are required to wear cameras
what's the argument against that so why
shouldn't we have cameras
in the classroom and now more than ever
it used to be we just
trusted what they were teaching our kids
now we know a lot of them
are demented and they're teaching poison
the biggest teachers uni in the country
just came out in support of racist
struggle session in kindergarten
meanwhile
the video we do have is not reassuring
at all over the past year you've seen
all kinds of cell phone footage
with teachers saying shocking things
berating vaccinated students for example
for not wearing their obedience masks
watch i don't care if you're vaccinated
your little
dink okay i don't want to get sick and
die
okay there's other people you can in
fact just because you're vaccinated you
know what you're not a special person
around here
you should hear about how everybody
talks about you i don't know
i don't care here i'm a jerk yeah that's
totally normal
so why don't we know what's going on in
classrooms well again last night we
suggested
what's the answer why shouldn't we and
not surprising a lot of people are very
offended by this you don't have a right
to know
shut up and send your kids don't ask
questions about what they're learning
about what kind of
people they're becoming
matt walsh hosts the matt wall show he's
one of the wise ones
we want to ask his viewers matt walsh
thanks so much for coming on tonight
this seemed this is one of these things
that someone suggested to me in
conversation yesterday morning i wish i
thought about myself
maybe people have been talking about it
i didn't know the second i heard i
thought that's the most obvious thing
i've ever heard why don't we do that
why don't we do that i guess let me ask
you that question
yeah well i mean first of all the the i
have to admit that the reform i would
prefer for this
the public school system is to just
destroy it you know reform it with a
wrecking ball
i don't think it should exist at all but
if it's going to exist then it's it's
it makes total sense that obviously we
should want to know
what our kids are being taught when
they're they're in these government
buildings maybe i think there are a lot
of parents who don't want to
confront or acknowledge what exactly
they're doing when they send their kid
to public school
you're sending them to a government
building for seven hours a day five days
a week
nine months a year for 12 years that's
what's happening you should want to know
what is going on what's what's going on
inside that building when they're there
all that time now
there i think there's there's the
there's the reason there's the real
reason
why the left doesn't want this and then
there's the reason that they give us
which of course
oftentimes are two different things the
reason they give us is that it's all
well it's a it's a privacy concern
or it's a free it's even a free speech
concern but first of all
teachers as government employees in
their capacity as government employees
working with kids
they shouldn't get privacy or free
speech anymore that i want
you know a bank teller if i'm making a a
deposit of a lot of cash i don't want
them to turn the cameras off
and go into a back room and say oh i
need some privacy while i do this
no we don't we don't privacy in your
capacity
handling money uh you send your dog to a
dog border
they've got webcams now so you can check
in anytime
so why wouldn't we want that kind of
oversight with kids and i think the real
reason
aside from the reasons they give us the
real reason is that
they just they don't want us to know
what goes on inside that door
but i think as you said we have a right
to know i mean look let's be totally
blunt here
i mean most teachers are great i'm
married to a former teacher i i'm not
against teachers but some teachers are
creepy
and we know that because they want to
talk to other people's pre-pubescent
kids
about sex in pretty detailed ways your
creep if you do that i mean let's just
be totally clear about it
so anyone who'd want to talk to like a
third grader about sex practices
don't you think we need to have a camera
on that person
yeah and that's that's another thing
where that shouldn't be happening at all
even with the camera right the grounds
happen and so we should have we should
have that kind of oversight i think
if there's anything you just just think
of it like this
is there anything that could happen
inside a public school classroom
that you absolutely would not want on
film
and if if you can think of something
that could happen like that
it shouldn't be happening in the in the
classroom to begin with whatever's
happening there
should be open for anyone to see um or
at least you know you could have the
cameras in there
and and parents who have custody of
children could have it could be password
protected if you could have the password
access
there are many ways of doing this that
make a lot of sense i think
but your point is the best point and i
wish i had said it if there's something
happening in a public school that
shouldn't be on film it shouldn't be
happening
in the first place and i it's kind of an
unassailable
point of reasoning and i appreciate matt
walsh thank you hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else